the young americas foundation uncovered
an incredible story
yesterday
yaf posted an article about a midwestern
elementary school
that is permitting the satanic temple
to host
satan club after school for the kids
jane adams elementary in illinois is
hosting multiple events
sponsored by the satanic temple
that it would be bad enough if they were
hosting their own events at the school
say after school hours but the events
are targeted at kids the event flyer
includes a permission slip for parents
to sign and says hey kids let's have fun
at after school satan club
now the school
had to issue a statement about this yaf
reached out to them
they said yes the satan club flyers are
posted around the elementary school
building
but they added quote religiously
affiliated groups are among those
allowed to rent our facilities for a fee
somewhere out there
somewhere out there in the recesses of
the squish
republican right
of the the most tired confused
talking points dated conservative
movement types
there are people who will say
this is a wonderful thing
this is a blessing of liberty
look the satanic temple i might not
agree with them
but the satanists have just as much of a
right as the methodists or the jews to
use
the school the elementary school for
their meetings
they
by golly would you tell presbyterians
they can't host their meetings would you
tell muslims they can't host their
meetings well then you can't say that to
the satanists either this country
was built on religious freedom
and pluralism
my goodness if we tell the satanists
that they can't recruit
10 year olds and younger for their
occult rituals
why the founding fathers would roll in
their graves
if this sort of thing occurred
during the era of the founding or
earlier in american history
all of those men the founding fathers
the earlier men who built our country
would currently be gathering kindling to
burn these people at the stake
okay i'm not suggesting we burn the
satanists at the stake necessarily but i
am suggesting that older generations of
americans would have the same
generations of americans that we pretend
in our insane revisionist history
were these
totally wide open-minded pluralistic
people
who considered
satanic meetings at the elementary
school as american as apple pie not at
all buster not even close
this is a complete rewriting of american
history a complete rewriting of the
american understanding of religious
freedom and pluralism
it is a philosophical misunderstanding
based on this idea that in america in a
liberal democracy such as america we
cannot tell people what is right or
wrong
no we just have to accept every single
idea and remain perfectly neutral
but
that's not possible it's not possible
not only do we need to talk about what
is right and wrong what's good and bad
what is the common good not only do we
do we need to talk about or do not only
should we talk about that we need to
talk about that it is inevitable it has
to happen
especially at elementary schools the
elementary school is already doing this
i promise you this elementary school has
lessons about how racism is bad
racism is bad i promise you
in probably every grade maybe every
class
do they need to remain neutral on racism
well we also need to represent the other
side is racism
good
i guarantee you they have
lessons about how
i don't probably they have lessons about
how transgenderism is is really good and
you can't oppose it are they going to
remain neutral no they can't because if
you teach one thing you can't teach
it's opposite you've got to talk about
good
and bad and you've got to in not only
talk about it you need to enforce
a conception of the common good it is
inevitable if we don't do it
the other side will there's no
neutrality low mortgage rates are still
available but they won't be around for
much longer so it's important to grab
one while you can
only takes 10 minutes to get started
when you call american financing which
is america's home for home loans you'll
get a free mortgage review from a salary
based mortgage consultant you can learn
about options before moving forward
there's no pressure there's no
obligation there's no upfront or hidden
fees they're not like that instead
they take the time to get to know you
first so they can design a custom loan
that saves you up to a thousand dollars
a month plus tens of thousands of
dollars in the long term
so why not take the time to learn more
you could skip two mortgage payments and
may close in as fast as 10 days call 800
685 56
that is 800-685-5696
or visit americanfinancing.net nmls
182-334-mls consumeraccess.org do not
wait head on over there right now save
some money be financially responsible
american financing america's home for
home loans the satanist after school
club
at this elementary school in illinois
where these creepy satan worshiping
adults go in to recruit kids
got me thinking
about all of the debates you hear about
in politics today
we've been told for a long time that the
big battle in the country is the left
versus the right or the big battle in
the country is the republicans versus
the democrats
or the
the big battle in the country is
i don't know freedom versus
socialism or the big battle in the
country is no michael it's not that it's
nationalism versus globalism
no it's
it's good versus evil
that's always what the political battle
is
and it rep
expresses itself in different ways so
yes you can have a battle over socialism
and you should be against socialism not
for social you have a battle over
whatever globalism
but ultimately its most basic level
the purpose of government
is do good and avoid evil
it's it's the same thing that we do in
our own lives
these other questions about freedom
equality justice
economics
they play a role in that too but the
basic thing is do good and avoid evil
and you can't do any of that you can't
have any conversation about liberty or
equality or justice if you don't have
some conception of the good and when
you've got satanists coming in to
elementary schools at literal actual
satanists coming into elementary schools
to recruit little kids and your
political philosophy can't allow you to
say anything against that can't allow
you to stop that then your political
philosophy sucks and doesn't make any
sense
and is not only completely out of step
with the american and western tradition
it simply
cannot
work
ah you know what to do
the bell you gotta ring the bell get the
notifications
you'll get all the new videos that come
out on this channel you go over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
what do you do you type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review you'll
get totally uncensored content too hot
for youtube you'll get it all over there
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you